[Music]  but what is this place what's your name  honey  I'm Joe I teach middle school band how'd  it go for today started out as the best  day of my life  back here tonight first shows at 7:00  you know what this gonna say Joe Gardner  I did I got the gig  must have been certain for you  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  huh no it's the grape before this is  where new Souls get their personalities  quirks and interest before they go to  earth mate twenty-two already know  everything about Earth and I don't want  anything to do with it you're missing  out on the joys of life like pizza I  can't smell we can't we can't taste  either all that stuff is in your body no  smell no taste or touch see okay  [Music]  is all this living really worth dying  for  you're so alive can you help me get back  no what are we waiting for  [Music]  hmm they sweet what does it 151,000  Saul's gone to the great beyond every  day you know I can't easily single one  of them that counts off  you